uh you often hear me on seminars that
say's
thing that's what I'm doing on this
I'm here what you're doing is you're now
going back into them and there's another
piece in my book that says don't go
backwards go forwards so I've gone here
now I'm actually going back there but I
really want him to
here so I chose this about a week ago
when I thought I'd like to
goach because it's following on really
from everything that I do you go I get
out of these distance and I
just I can pass it by
here I don't need to take it back into
him I pass it by here
so it's it's sort of going on what we
done before the AA
see making a a big distance
now so I don't want you're watching when
I used to be student I used to
watch first legs and then can I look at
oh no I can't so so you have to pick
bits
work out what bit you want to work with
or what bit you thought you saw but why
is it different than
the the first one even with the move I
was about here in line with his
foot okay and then down there this one
you need to watch the
back puts
me so I'm actually
floting footwork
wise very